seid ihr bereit für meine vielen süßen
grip cakes ich zeige euch dem video wie
ihr sie ganz einfach zubereitet und wie
ihr den perfekten grip hinbekommen also
kommt einfach mal mit
[Musik]
wir starten jetzt zuallererst mit
unseren vier böten dafür habe ich hier
meinen backpapier und meine mini
tortenring und wir machen jetzt
folgendes wir nehmen uns ist backpapier
und tigers durch vier
weil dadurch dass jetzt die torten ringe
keinen boden haben das fragen wir doch
mal ganz viele nach nehmen uns einfach
ein backpapier und kleiden quasi den
tortenring mit backpapier aus damit wir
einfach safety unterlage haben das auch
gar nichts raus weil raus gewinnen kann
und ja wir einfach da auf der sicheren
seite sein
[Musik]
meine törtchen werden im durchmesser so
ungefähr zehn zentimeter seien daher
einmal auf 10 cm einstellen ich werde
euch in die infobox verlinken genauso
wie alle anderen dinge die ich hier
benutzte und sogar überlegt dass wir so
einen spaß erstellen der haben soll
macht das weil man schaffte ich es halt
einmal an und man hat es dann für immer
und meistens braucht man danach mehrere
teile und da ist so ein spaß hat
eigentlich ganz cool und jetzt nehmen
wir uns hier einmal das backpapier und
dann immer in so knicken den bewegungen
um den tortenring herum
und irgendwann kommt der am ende an und
merkt dass es halt bombenfest ist
[Musik]
so wenn ihr am ende angekommen seid
einfach an den ring dran knicken und
jetzt könnte das anheben und ich sagte
ja es ist bombenfest also da kann nichts
mehr passieren und so mache ich weiter
mit den drei weiteren ring und danach
mache ich auch schon den teig
[Musik]
dadurch dass jetzt ein sehr
unkompliziert des rezeptes habe ich
natürlich auch gedacht machen wir einen
super unkomplizierten teig ich nehme mir
jetzt meine ja die werde ich nicht
trennen ich gebe ihnen die schüssel
direkt zusammen mit zucker und vanille
extrakt und dann werde ich das einfach
mit einem handrührgerät drei minuten
lang auf maximaler geschwindigkeit
richtig schön hell cremig schlagen
[Musik]
handrührgerät habe ich an die seite
getan jetzt geht's weiter mit unserem
teig schade denn ihr wisst bei trockenen
zutaten wenn wir die unterheben immer
mit einem teig schaber und mit ganz viel
liebe und am besten auch noch in
mehreren schritten ich gehe jetzt in
meinem mail einmal in meinen sie da kann
backpulver auch schon direkt dazu
dann fange ich an zu suchen es reicht
jetzt aber schon dass wir ungefähr ein
drittel und jetzt von außen nach innen
richtig schön unterheben dann mache ich
immer so weiter bis die trockenen
zutaten komplett aufgebraucht sind
[Musik]
so der teig ist fertig und jetzt werde
ich ihn einmal gleichmäßig einzeln in
die torten ringe das coole ist es einmal
eine tortenring halt so eine skala haben
und da könnt ihr dann genau sehen ob ihr
bei allen ringen gleichmäßig viel
aufgefüllt habt ich habe persönlich
nämlich kein gutes augenmaß ich weiß
nicht wie es bei euch ist aber ich
orientiere mich da halt immer und guckt
bei wenn sie dann gleichmäßig hoch
eingefüllt werden dann sind sie auch
gleich gleich schnell gar quasi und ich
dass der eine dann noch roh ist unter
anderem schon gebacken
[Musik]
so die törtchen sind gerade für den
backofen 180 grad ober und unterhitze
mir ist wichtig dass sie den wirklich
komplett vor heisst und dann werden sie
für 24 minuten gebacken anschließend
bedenklich sie mit einem tuch lanci
vollständig auskühlen aber wir nutzen
natürlich die zwischenzeit und machen
dann die creme bis gleich
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt eine basic creme eine
basic vanillecreme die wir später noch
aufpeppen also auffinden mit
verschiedenen dingen während wir das
ganze schichten und dafür nehme ich
jetzt einfach eine große schüssel gibt
da sahen rein die sollte ganz kalt sein
ich habe sie ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank geholt und die sahne werde
ich zusammen mit seiner festen steif
schlagen und dann geht es weiter mit
meiner mascarpone
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sobald die sonne dann komplett steif ist
machen wir weiter in der nächsten
schüsse ihr könnt das ganze natürlich
auch mit eurer küchenmaschine machen
aber ich wollte es einfach zeigen das
ist halt auch mit einem handrührgerät
geht und da habe ich jetzt hier die
mascarpone drin da habe ich auch frisch
aus dem kühlschrank zucker mit rein und
wann der extrakt das ganze dann mit dem
handrührgerät wirklich nur zehn sekunden
rühren mehr braucht ihr da gar nicht und
dann habe ich wieder mit ganz viel liebe
mit einem touch aber die sahne unter dem
ast ab ohne creme
[Musik]
die törtchen sind jetzt auch vollständig
ausgekühlt und ich habe sie einmal mit
meinem backform löser vom ring entfernt
und ich habe richtig knuffig aus ich
werde jetzt folgendes tun einfach alle
hier einmal vom backpapier befreien es
geht ganz einfach
und dann nehmen wir uns einfach die
torten säge das coole ist wenn man einer
tollen serie die hätte eine echte klinge
das heißt ihr könnt da selbst frische
törtchen ganz easy durchschneiden ohne
dass ihr euch großartig zerbröseln und
viele fragen wir wie das funktioniert
ich demonstriere ich das einmal ihr habt
hier keine stufen das heißt ihr könnt
sie stufenlos verstellen das liegt
einfach daran dass jeder boden
individuell hoch buck das heißt das
gleiche rezept kann morgen heim
zentimeter kürzer sein und daher
lieblichkeit dass man das stufenlos
verstellen kann ich nehme dann immer
einfach genial oder halt hier meine teig
karte zu hilfe halt dran cook wie hoch
ich immer die einzelnen böden haben
möchte und muss mich gar nicht festlegen
auf eine stufe und dann geht ihr einfach
dran und schiebt bis hin und her wichtig
ist dass ihn mit dem finger hier oben
bleibt und nicht aus versehen hier unten
an sitzt weil dann verschiebt er die
klinge wieder also ich hier oben
ansetzen und dann ganz einfach
durchschneiden
[Musik]
die böden sind fertig durchgeschnitten
die creme ist fertig und jetzt gehts
eigentlich nur noch ins dekorieren und
ich habe mir im vorfeld gedanken gemacht
welche farben ich mit welchem grip
kombiniere mit welcher
geschmacksrichtung und dafür nehme ich
mir jetzt circa 1 4 denn die creme
reicht dafür vier törtchen einmal weg
denn du fertig also ein für die
fertigkeit nicht ein das bleibt schön
weiß daher direkt einmal wegschnappen
spritzbeutel geben da werde ich gleich
einfach nur von die spitze abschneiden
und dann bin ich da einfach flexibler
was das dekorieren und füllen angeht so
und die restlichen drei vierte die ich
jetzt übrig habe die teile ich jetzt
einmal auf da werde ich einen teil rosa
einfärben den anderen teil geld dann
nämlich einfach lebensmittel geht haben
und ein teil in braun und da brauchte
keine farbe für könnte natürlich auch
nehmen aber für den geschmack könnt ihr
da einfach bei cacau hinzu 7 und einfach
umrühren und heftig dass auch brown
[Musik]
jetzt geht's an den schönsten bart in
diesem video wir werden jetzt alles
schön schichten und dekorieren ich habe
wie gesagt ganz viele verschiedene
geschmäcker überlegt und da starte ich
jetzt mit den ersten zwei und das werden
fruchtige geschmäcker und ich finde
gerade außerhalb der saison kann man
frucht chips ganz gut leben das sind
meine fruchtig sie sind nämlich
gefriergetrocknet und die kann man das
ganze jahr über snacken die schmecken
sehr intensiv daher braucht ja auch
nicht so viel davon ich habe super viele
verschiedene varianten die lege ich
erstmal zur seite denn für dieses video
habe ich mich entschieden für erdbeer
und himbeer und da fange ich jetzt
einfach an die torten jetzt mit meinem
krebs zu schichten und eben die frucht
schützt darin zu verteilen
[Musik]
die zwei flüchtigen varianten sind jetzt
fertig ich hab sie ab in den kühlschrank
getan damit sie richtig schön durch
kühlen und jetzt habe ich noch zwei
varianten die eine mache ich mit bananen
da könnt ihr auch getrocknete bananen
nehmen oder halt frische deshalb wird
auch frische deswegen stelle ich die
gleich einfach in sehr dünne scheiben
und dann habe ich noch überlegt bei dem
schokotörtchen nehmen wir einfach
ferrero rocher das ganze wie immer
schichten schönberg verstreichen und
dann müssen alle törtchen für eine
stunde richtig schön durch kühlen damit
wir sie halt für den trip vorbereiten
können sagt und ich darf jetzt einfach
mal
[Musik]
die törtchen sind bei mir jetzt komplett
durch gekühlt und jetzt kommt der druck
auf die torten dieses video ist für alle
die schon mein trip zu hause haben ich
habe nämlich capes ganz frisch
rausgebracht in verschiedenen farben und
es kommen auch gerne noch mehr farben
dazu schreibt man einfach in die
kommentare welche euch fehlt und dann
nehmen wir das gerne noch mit auf und
viele mal gefragt kannst du mein video
damit machen und zeigen dies
funktioniert was ist das problem bei
einem normalen grippe ich verlinke euch
in die info box mine gebohrt meine
geburtstagstorte von vor ein paar jahren
da habe ich auch schon einen schritt
machen wollen ich wollte ihnen gerne
rosa er ist aber irgendwie in einer ganz
anderen farbe heraus gekommen weil es
sehr schwierig ist einen schoko trip
quasi in der wunschfarbe einzufärben und
es ist immer wie eine überraschungstüte
man weiß halt nie wirklich welche farbe
am ende rauskommt so und beim eingriff
ist es so der ist halt gebrauchsfertig
und der trocknet ultraschnell das heißt
er wird euch nicht weg fließen sondern
ihr habt wirklich einen schönen grip und
die gebrauchsanweisung muss auch ganz
einfach entweder für eine minute in die
mikrowelle tun dann wird sie schön
flüssig hatte dann aber auch wieder aus
oder einfach in warmes wasser legen für
ein paar minuten bis es dann halt auch
wieder flüssig wird und keine sorge wenn
ihr nicht beim 1 bei einem mal das ganze
verbraucht was halt wirklich immer der
fall ist ihr könnt es 34 mal verwenden
dann könnt ihr da einfach immer wieder
erwärmen und ich würde sagen ich würde
dafür viel drumherum ich drehe die kappe
einmal auf jetzt ist die öffnung da und
wir können ganz einfach hier am rand
entlang herunterdrücken
und immer darauf achten dass der chip
nicht ganz auf dem boden kommt nämlich
die geheime regel eines trips
also ich habe hier noch ein tipp für
euch drückt nicht zur veste und wirklich
hier nur am rand so ein bisschen muss
runter laufen dass mir bekommt schnell
ein gefühl dafür wie feste ihr da auf
der tube drücken müsst aber meistens
wirklich so ein ganz leichter stoß und
wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr gleich
die komplette mitte einmal mit dem grip
voll machen oder in das ballast ist halt
wirklich beim rand das könnt ihr einfach
je nachdem entscheiden was für optik
ihrer möchte ich werde gleich nochmal
getrocknete früchte obendrauf geben und
wie gesagt ist trocknet wirklich ultra
schnell bewusst damit die handhabung
einfach ist und der dritte nicht ganz
bis zum boden läuft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für alle die jetzt bis zum schluss dran
geblieben sind habe ich mir noch etwas
richtig cooles über die ich wollte
gucken wer bleibt wirklich bis zum
schluss dran und passt wirklich auch und
für diejenigen gibt es jetzt noch ein
gewinnspiel wir haben uns nämlich
überlegt dass es vier asse im shop geben
wird weil ich finds halt einfach
superpraktisch dann kann man sich seine
vier wunschfarben aussuchen und dieses
set werde ich viermal fünfmal aus fünf
mal an euch verlosen also 5 mal 1 4 as
it was müsst ihr dafür tun schreibt man
einfach eure zwei liebsten farben von
den cache trips auch in die kommentare
und dann erkenne ich dass sie mitmacht
ihr landet im lostopf und eine woche
später werde ich dann die gewinne
anschreiben und das paket losschicken
falls ihr euch jetzt fragt wonach die
capes schmecken einfach schokolade
findet euch jetzt ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen von den süßen minijob cakes
wünsche euch noch einen wunderschönen
tag und sage bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]